(upbeat music)
- Abbi, can you repeat from
"Just look at me go," so I can
see this...
- Alana and I are directing
for the first time this season,
two episodes each.
It's been really cool.
- [Ilana] Oh, my god, dude,
directing has been fucking dope.
- You let me know if
you need anything, okay?
- Thanks, love you.
- Good luck, dude.
- Watch me go, pretend I
just left, and go for it.
So then maybe we'll
get in Mike's shot,
it's like right from
me to you, and get that
whole thing in 'oner'.
- Okay, here we go.
(camera clicking)
Goddamnit!
So when Ilana write an episode
together, we split up acts.
It's like we're always trying
to make the other person
laugh, and when we come
back, it's like (laughs) see!
And so directing, we
did not direct together.
We each directed two
episodes separately.
But my time in the edit,
before it got to Ilana,
I felt it was the same feeling.
It was exciting to get to
fully develop my vision,
and to finish it up, and get
to show it to Ilana in the
next phase.
- So you two have
the same thermos.
- Oh, wow, that's neat.
- [Woman] Same wheely cart, too.
- Oh.
- Soul sisters! (laughs)
- Scene 11, take
one, and the mark.
- [Abbi] It was a really
long day at the Met.
I was in every single
scene and directing.
So we have second team, which
is like stand-ins for us,
so we can set-up the shot,
see how we like how it looks,
and then we like how the
action's going to go,
and then we jump in,
and while you're in the scene,
you have to be in the scene
as an actor, but also conscious
of the whole scene as a
director.
It's another layer on top
of what we've already done,
and it's been really satisfying
for me, in a new way.
- Hey, Margo, can you watch
my stuff for a second?
I've got money to spend.
Money is a mind-control
technique that quantifies the
progress of the patriarchy!
Yeah, I'll watch your stuff.
- Okay, thanks!
- Yeah.
- Hello, hello, hello, Beverly
Baumgarten, we're here!
- Hi, there!
- [Ilana] My first day
of directing, I directed
Fran Drescher.
And Susie Essman, and
Eliot Glazer, my brother.
It was a dream.
In the morning, I was like
(squeals) girl squealing.
That was like really easy,
the typical coverage.
I could simultaneously be in
it acting, and feeling what
was funniest, and which
were the best takes.
Then we got to this shot that
was "That 70s Show" style,
360 smoking thing, my
camera-man's monitor
was on the floor,
so I was watching the scene as
though I was behind, and then
once it swiveled to me, I was
in the scene, that tripped
me out.
But otherwise, I don't find
it that hard, because it feels
like we're directing
when we're in it anyway.
I think that's
great. We got it all.
Because we've been with
our crew for so long,
they can make certain decisions
and have a short hand.
Our DP, Chris Teague,
he's incredible.
When we were shot-listing,
for a few times,
I would have to get up
and be in the scene to see
where I would picture
a camera coming over.
I'm like, "Pan this way,
and then you see it."
And he was like, "No, first
we should see it, and then pan
that way? Maybe you're right."
I'm like, "No,
maybe you're right."
And then we go back-and-forth.
And I'm like, "I think I'm
'Justin Birding' it because I'm
usually in front of the camera."
I'm loving it.
It's as though this
final puzzle piece
is clicking in, for me.
It takes out a layer of work
that is: explaining shit to
the director, telling
them where we...
Oh, my god!
Okay, just real quick,
pan... (smooching)
Hello! Catcalling dogs! (laughs)
It just cuts all that out.
So it's actually kind of
easier, in a way, to direct.
It really is.
It's easier to direct your
own show, in a way, for us.